ubisoft est dans la tourmente depuis
plusieurs jours le géant du jeu vidéo
est accusée d'entretenir une culture
d'entreprise toxiques ou les femmes qui
composent environ 20% des équipes sont
victimes d'harcèlement sexuel et
psychologique
la semaine dernière ubisoft a montré la
porte à son ancien président canadien
visé par des allégations de
comportements sexistes et d'abus de
pouvoir
alors comment les entreprises
peuvent-elles lutter contre ce genre de
comportement au sein de leur équipe j'en
parle avec caroline coty qui présidente
fondatrice la gouvernance au féminin
bonjour madame coty bonjour merci d'être
avec nous c'est un sujet chaud on a
parlé beaucoup vous savez de ces vague
de dénonciations première question que
doivent faire les entreprises face à ce
genre de dénonciation mais écoutez
d'abord il faut prendre les choses très
sérieusement il faut que le mécanisme en
place qu'ils soient claires quand on est
victime d'harcèlement que ce soit
psychologique que ce soit sexuelle que
ce soit des comportements que ce soit
des mots peu importe et qu'on voudrait
amener la tension de la haute direction
des ressources humaines
comment s'y prend ton est ce que c'est
clairement énoncé au sein de
l'organisation et surtout est-ce que je
vais être prise au sérieux en tant
qu'employé qui amène cette question-là
trop souvent les femmes ont peur d'être
soit congédié soit mise à l'écart ou
qu'on ne pense pas elle pour des
promotions parce qu'elles ont parlé
alors ça c'est un problème qui réel et
dans toutes les industries
bien que dans le domaine tech
probablement encore plus que dans les
autres davantage
est-ce qu'on voit une hausse actuelle
mal de secrets d'harcèlement sexuel et
psychologiques dans le milieu de travail
écoutez je vais pas jusqu'à dire qu'il
ya une hausse des comportements mais
probablement une hausse des
dénonciations
vous savez moi j'ai 30 ans d'expérience
dans le monde corporatif au canada je ne
connais pas une simple qui n'a pas à un
moment donné ou à un autre
hu a transigé avec des comportements qui
sont inacceptables c'est sûr qu'il ya 25
ans on était moins amené à dénoncer on
n'avait pas le courage c'était pas
quelque chose qui se faisait aussi
ouvertement qu'aujourd'hui donc je pense
que la vague qu'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est tout simplement des femmes qui ont
pris le courage de dénoncer parce
qu'elles en ont vu d'autres le faire
parce qu'elles ont vu des congédiements
avoir lieu que ça les a assurés on
pouvait les prendre au sérieux plus
encore la réalité à 2020 il faut le dire
c'est plus difficile dons pour les
femmes de monter dans l'entreprise et
par rapport à cette vague de
dénonciations madame cathy est ce que
vous voyez ça donc se poursuivre lors
des prochaines années là je pense que
oui mais je pense également qu en
parallèle les organisations vont
implanter des politique de tolérance
zéro pour tous ces comportements là
c'est certain qu'en même temps il faut
qu'on fasse attention de ne pas aller
trop loin parce qu'il faut pas non plus
que les hommes deviennent mal à l'aise
en présence de femmes à la gouvernance
au féminin on a un programme de mentorat
ou des femmes vice-présidente d'une
grosse d'organisation sont montrés par
des hommes et des femmes qui sont pdg et
on ne voudrait pas comment m'en donner
au mot dix mois en tant qu'homme je ne
suis pas à l'aise dans ma part est une
femme donc c'est un couteau à double
tranchant il faut faire attention mais
il est évident que de mettre en place un
environnement de travail sain et
inclusive
ça c'est indéniable et je vous dirais
que le poste le plus en demande et le
poste de chef diversité et l'inclusion
et que ça fait partie maintenant de
toutes les organisations d'envergure si
ccc intégral à la culture à la capacité
à gérer une entreprise sans ce genre de
problème qui quittent vont surgir
surtout dans des milieux dominé par les
hommes
quand ce sont des hommes qui sont à la
tête de l'organisation qui a vraiment
aucune parité comme on peut le voir à
ubisoft c'est indispensable de mettre
des politiques claires et de s'y coller
ça c'est la bonne nouvelle également que
vous dite fière de ce type de poste qui
existe de plus en plus est ce que ça
existe encore le fameux boys club
alors vous savez d'espèces de groupes
masculins qui est fermé mais qui part à
toutes les décisions là écoutez le boys
club qui existe depuis depuis toujours
il n'a pas disparu c'est certain
maintenant beaucoup d'organisations ou
même la plupart se targue de tête à la
recherche de candidates féminines ou
issus de la diversité parce que toutes
les études démontrent qu'une présence
accrue de femmes ou de personnes issues
de la diversité dans les organes
décisionnels des entreprises mènent à
plus d'innovation mène à une meilleure
performance financière à une plus
robuste prise de décision et c'est donc
les organisations serait ridicule de ne
pas vouloir s'entourer de diversité mais
il reste que on voit encore des conseils
d'administration au canada des sociétés
cotées en bourse où il n'y a pas une
seule femme ou c'est une table d'hommes
pour la plupart blanc pour la plupart
dans les mêmes groupes d'âge et qui
sombre trop souvent dans ce qu'on
appelle le groupe 5/7 une pensée unique
où tout le monde est d'accord on arrive
à un consensus rapidement mais qui
pourtant ne reflète pas du tout la
société est alors comment développer un
produit comment avoir une offre que l'on
propose à nos consommateurs
si on n'est pas capable de prendre en
considération toutes les opinions autour
de la table est-ce que c'était dans
certains milieux qui sont davantage
masculin comme celui des jeux vidéo
alors est-ce qu'on recrute moins de
femmes dans ce type de secteur écoutez
ce que vous parlez d'ubisoft parce que
je les connais bien la gouvernance au
féminin on a développé une certification
parité depuis bientôt quatre ans avec le
soutien de mckinsey & company et cette
certification ubisoft fait partie des
organisations pionnière donc les
entreprises qui ont démarré en 2017 dans
ce processus là et qui depuis ont
vraiment progressé on a vu des
désorganisations qui resserrait l'écart
entre les genres de manière concrète en
suivant les recommandations qu'on leur
faisait malheureusement ubisoft n'a fait
qu'une seule année et ils ont abandonné
le navire
donc alors ça je trouve ça vraiment
triste par contre je les salue quand
même pour certaines activités qu'ils
font pour que plus de jeunes filles
choisissent comme discipline académique
d d d d d orientation plus hautes
technologies par exemple il avait invité
l'année dernière zuckerberg la soeur de
l'autre de facebook
lokeren zuckerberg est une femme en
haute technologie que j'ai eu le bonheur
d'ailleurs d'interviewer à la place des
arts dans 3000 personnes
il y avait des centaines de jeunes
femmes qui avaient été invités par
ubisoft dont qui n'ont pas payé pour
écouter les conseils de randi zuckerberg
pour faire sa place
un milieu en hautes technologies donc ça
bravo il faut quand même rendre à césar
ce qui est à césar ce qui est quand même
déplorable que hal interne il n'y ait
pas plus de mécanismes plus de
politiques plus d'initiatives pour
permettre aux femmes de progresser sans
planches et collants sans plafond de
verre et surtout sans harcèlement ait
encore beaucoup de chemin à parcourir
merci beaucoup malades continuent
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous merci